las horas transcurren lentamente para
decenas de refugiados afganos que llevan
semanas acampados en el aeropuerto de
San Pablo a la espera de que salga una
plaza en una casa de acogida
paraguasic la hora del té es Sagrada
Este joven periodista pertenece a la
etnia hasara perseguida por los
talibanes es uno de los 4.500 afganos
que han llegado a Brasil en el último
año
vinimos aquí en busca de una situación
mejor en la esperanza de encontrar una
sociedad sin discriminación para poder
continuar nuestros estudios
tener derecho a trabajar
a una vida mejor
tuvo que huir dejando atrás a su familia
en bamillán la ciudad donde los
talibanes destruyeron las estatuas
gigantes primero se refugió en Irán
donde consiguió un visado para Brasil
Ahora tiene que lidiar con otra
situación precaria en un país
desconocido no tenemos baño ni cocina
los niños no ven La luz del sol
es la situación dura pero nos traen
Comida
hay personas que nos ayudan y también
voluntarios
eso es muy importante para nosotros
Brasil es el único país de América
Latina que concede visados humanitarios
a los afganos en total fueron emitidos
cerca de 6000 Visas
sin embargo el gobierno de Jair
bolsonaro no otorgó fondos para la
manutención de estos refugiados todo el
peso recae sobre la ciudad de guarullios
donde se encuentra el Aeropuerto
Internacional
desde el inicio de la llegada de los
primeros afganos en enero 2022
el ayuntamiento de guarulos ha realizado
una acción de acogida para esas personas
en agosto ese número creció absurdamente
Así que pasamos de cuatro o cinco
personas al mes a 200 entonces la acción
humanitaria precisa ser más fuerte
nosotros garantizamos la seguridad
alimentaria de estas personas a través
del desayuno el almuerzo y la cena está
portavoz de acnur la agencia de la ONU
para los refugiados explica que la
inmigración afgana en Brasil es un
fenómeno novedoso cerca del 50% de los
refugiados tiene estudios superiores
entonces son las personas que tienen más
ingresos incluso porque llegar hasta
Brasil comprar el billete es bastante
caro estos afganos llegan con muchas
expectativas de conseguir un buen
trabajo de trabajar en su área de
formación hay periodistas políticos
médicos enfermeros incluso colegas
nuestros de las Naciones Unidas
en la actualidad hay más de tres
millones y medio de refugiados afganos
en el mundo acnur Espera que el ejemplo
de Brasil pueda ser replicado en otros
países latinoamericanos
cuando por fin consiguen dejar el
aeropuerto de guarullios estos asilados
encuentran cobijo en casas comunes
Este joven de 29 años llegó solo su
familia tuvo que quedarse en Irán desde
el inicio de diciembre vive en este
cuarto que comparte con otros
compatriotas
somos seis personas hay una cama para
cada uno
y esta es mi cama
su prioridad ahora es aprender portugués
cuanto antes para poder reanudar sus
estudios su sueño es ser ingeniero
a lo mejor voy a trabajar mientras se
acaba la universidad
en el futuro quiero que venga mi familia
y que podamos vivir en un sitio mejor
como Brasil
la llegada de los afganos supone un reto
para las organizaciones humanitarias que
lidian con ellos En primera línea
cada movimiento migratorio tiene una
especificidad Y esta es una cultura muy
específica
pero tienen un idioma solo hablen más de
una lengua
muchos son dialectos hay dificultad para
comunicarse para comer para dialogar con
las mujeres porque un hombre que habla
que toma las decisiones
además hay tres etnias que llegan que
tienen un conflicto histórico que
terminan quedándose en el mismo espacio
en el mismo lugar son todos desafíos
otra dificultad es mantener sus
costumbres Como por ejemplo encontrar
carne halal cortada según el Rito
musulmán
las mujeres afganas prefieren cocinar su
propia comida para matar la nostalgia De
su tierra Porque todos ellos se vieron
obligados a marcharse algún día Les
gustaría volver pero solo a un país en
paz